the Holy Father has raised some eyebrows
because Pope Francis has welcomed a
group of marxists and talked about how
wonderful it is to have dialogue between
Christians and
marxists it is not in my job description
to criticize the Holy Father I I might
raise some questions though here's what
the pope said I'm pleased to welcome you
the representatives of Diop who for many
years have been committ to promoting the
common good through dialogue between
socialists marxists and Christians a
fine program I would like to commend you
commend to you three attitudes that I
consider helpful to your efforts first
have the courage to break them old to be
open in dialogue to new ways instead of
rigid approaches that divide let us
cultivate with Open Hearts discussion
and listening and not exclude anyone at
the political social or religious level
second concern for the less fortunate
sure that's great finally the rule of
law dear friends I thank you for your
commitment to die dialog okay I'm a
little confused here
because many many popes
for nearly 100 years now coming up on it
have in no uncertain terms condemned
communism and socialism and said that
Christianity can have nothing to do with
socialism and Marxism Blessed Pope Pas
the 9th and qu plos in 1846 all the way
back said communism as it is called as a
Doctrine most opposed to the very natur
natural law speaking of natural law for
if this Doctrine were accepted the
complete destruction of everyone's laws
government property and even to Human
Society itself would follow well you
might say that's just one Pope right no
no it's not just one Pope Pope Leo the
13th in 1901 says a harvest of misery is
before our eyes and the Dreadful
projects of the most disastrous National
upheavals are threatening us from The
Growing Power of the socialistic
movement okay pute Benedict the 15th
1914 it is not our intention here to
repeat the arguments which clearly
expose the errors of socialism and of
similar doctrines our predecessor Leo
the 13th most wisely did so in truly
memorable encyclicals and you venerable
Brethren will take the greatest care
that the those grave precepts are never
to be forgotten not even in 2024 when
people forget a lot of things Pope Pius
the 11 no one can at the same time be a
good Catholic and a true socialist he
goes on he lests socialism papayas the
11 too few have been able to grasp the
nature of Communism the majority instead
succumb to deception skillfully
concealed by the most extravagant
promises Pope Pas I 12th says the same
thing Pope John the 23rd who's who is a
liberal Pope at least that's how he's
considered says no Catholic could
subscribe even to moderate socialism
Pope Paul V considered a liberal Pope
said much the same thing Pope John Paul
II constantly invade against socialism
and communism I mean the man is
considered an anti-communist hero of the
20th century Pope Benedict the 16th who
was the most recent Pope uh before
Francis said uh the state which would
provide everything absorb everything
into itself would ultimately become a
mere bureaucracy incapable of
guaranteeing the very thing which the
suffering person every person needs
namely loving personal concern says we
don't need this we don't need any of
that
okay what is going on
here Pope francis's comments are very
confusing I've made no bones about the
fact that I'm a mackerel snapping papist
myself I find it very confusing and I
find it confusing
because the church is teaching on
communism and socialism is not at all
confusing not at all I I just quoted a
handful of the I could we I fill up many
shows talking about what the Catholic
church has said about condemning Marxism
and socialism so what's really going on
here in charity and to give Pope Francis
the benefit of the doubt I suspect that
he's drawn in to this kind of a dialogue
in the way that a lot of good people are
drawn in to to want to have a dial
dialogue with Marxism and communism
because you you actually do have a care
for the common good and you care for the
poor as Pope Francis said and you care
for those who' been left out you want
rule of law and you don't want the
predations of a totally untethered um
liberal liberalized regime where of of
leair capitalism where no one cares at
all about anyone else and everyone's
just avaricious and trying to to um
pursue his own personal interests to the
exclusion of a common good I I I get
that and they think that Marxism does
that but it doesn't and the the left
misunderstands that the the good ones on
the left misunderstand that the bad ones
on the left are fine with it they just
you know they they're deceptive and
duplicitous the thing is a lot of people
on the right misunderstand this too I
was talking to a friend of mine years
ago who suggested he was very deeply
read in marks and he
said if KL Mars were alive today he
would not be on the left or or he would
be on the left but he wouldn't be a
Democrat he if Carl Marx were alive
today he would be in the tea party Carl
Marx is a radical
libertarian and I've had other Anarchist
friends and libertarian friends who have
made that point very few people have
actually read marks everyone talks about
marks very a few people have actually
read marks I from what I have read of
marks which is probably more than most
people though I have nowhere near the
man's total Corpus uh I agree with
them I think what Marx was after was
total
Liberation that's that's the Utopia at
the end of Marxism is is a world of
total freedom freedom not not in the
traditional sense of order and
responsibility in toward the natural
order and natural hierarchies and man's
natural ends and doing what you ought to
do no no no the modern kind of Freedom
where you just do whatever the hell you
want all the time that's what Marx was
after the the Utopia at the end of the
of the Marxist program is where you get
to do just whatever the hell you want
all the time and that that is the
libertarian view of
Freedom it's a hard saying the
Libertarians would say no we're the
we're the opposite of the marxists
they're the collectivists we're the
individualists Carl Marx would probably
call himself a radical
individualist because they're two sides
of the same
coin Because the
actual opposition to communism to
Marxism to collectivism is not radical
individualism it's the family its
structure its order its hierarchy it's
tradition it's inertia it's the weight
of History radical collectivism and
radical individualism are both
revolutionary programs that that pour
acid on all of the institutions of
society that are both equally opposed to
the family and to tradition and to
everything that has come before
us that's that's the
issue and so
ironically what I think all those past
popes were warning about was that in in
Catholic Social teaching there's plenty
of concern about leier capitalism going
too far about individualism going too
far which is why you need protections of
the common good which which is different
than collectivism you know the
collectivism that the left talks about
is this kind of bizarre modern clinical
utilitarianism where we determine the
common good by figuring out
out I don't know the the most pleasure
for the greatest number of people where
we ignore individual rights where we say
well you know if 50% plus one benefit
from something then screw the minority
that's not truly the common good the the
true common good is everyone's
individual good as well and it
presupposes that we can know our own
good that our own good is not just
whatever you wake up Desiring that
morning but that that the good of man
can be known objectively through the use
of reason we were talking earlier about
the natural law that's what that's about
things have a purpose the leftist tears
tumbler has a purpose it gives me my
delicious leftist tears the microphone
on my lapel has a purpose it transmits
my malous voice to your ears man has a
purpose some of our organs have purposes
the eye has the purpose which is to
perceive the the visual world and and
allow us to interact with it in a
reliable way we hope other other organs
have purposes man has a purpose an
ultimate end too we can know it and we
can all flourish man that was a great
clip huh I agree make sure that you ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael and
old Show
podcast we'll see you next time